there we go
[Music]
- Angela
hi Eddie so honey limo pizza papa
what then
anyways me David as a Jew we have a
question we don't believe God can become
a man so the question that is proposed
to you from us the Jews and the Muslims
is what makes you believe God is a man
where is a man become in a man it speaks
about Jesus Christ Jesus Christ be God
and also speaks about him being a man oh
no what do you mean confirm and while
we're talking a concern because now you
change the topic we talked about me and
David Kim well God can be yes now
exactly I want to talk about Lee so I
didn't call you don't cut me off here
the first question was this me and David
a Muslim and a Jew
came and asked our Christian friends the
people of the book a question why do you
believe God is a man powerful being
limited
quickly then this is what you're really
interested in here you pose a question
to me in my religious Scripture
it doesn't say God can be a man in the
Old Testament or the Tanakh anyway this
is a good can be a man we both we both
protect that now as a Muslim I one
second to
[Music]
there's no not like you find the wording
but the page does not appear does not
mean to the way you do is our saying
someone before bargain is outer wisdom
you understand what God means and the
appearance you are trying to understand
God in the human contact exactly but to
understand
and we want an understanding so good was
literally economy our premature because
this is later on in this trend in the
owning the Bible there when Moses I
don't know it because I was trying to
prove right where's the Muslims and
Christians you do it we don't you based
a lot on reciting scripture Isis Jews
don't base lot on the actual reciting
scripture we know where is because those
remarks don't help you I'm seeing I'm
going to accept you you nominated me
he's not gonna accept my book my
scripture so he's one second one second
this will be very simple what we all
agree on
can we all agree on fundamentally this
is gonna give you a headache because
you're gonna like it
can we all agree that there is a
universal understanding of God Almighty
he is the most powerful he's the most
knowing and the most powerful one second
because we now is David asking is
powerful this is in vain as we're saying
this is not what you think how
[Music]
okay yes Abraham okay why are you why
are you avoiding this yes yes with him
agree with you change this to America
you know I do by the English I don't
think you learn what you read which
Bible jury which that's my question
but with my question
which bible jury cream change all of
your Bibles going the original you see I
learn the Bible what we call guitar in
the original tax owed to the Muslims
they learn what they believe in the
original tech you lot run around the
transformation all right
translation I learn in the original
language in the age with Hebrew language
in Arabic language in the Bible in
English you see in your book is true
when you dive into the topic let's come
back
is God or is is go to powerful finish
one when is
[Music]
okay bring the Hebrew you learn this
scripture in a different language that
was written yes forget which is true
from common sense if we learn in the
original language it's more likely to be
true we both learn our scriptures in the
original language you on the other hand
learning a language that is new so it's
English that's another thing we have in
common you can change it means there's
no way no way to verify because you are
the king you have a King James Bible I
bring a rational but you can say with
difference we Jews we all have the same
scriptures okay and so David we have
something in common we both believe God
is not a man
and we both our own scriptures in our
yes and as a Muslim
why can I say something
okay Jie Jie and I'm we all agreed God
is not a man yes this is we have
something in common with Jewish
so are you see okay this is food
nope I'm not saying you don't know you
can now you agree my books of truth
teaching in Judaism words camisa a word
can mean not two different things
actually the one mean black and white
yes that one Jews when you describe that
what is used when it discusses when God
appears in a prophecy it's not like when
you were
here's an example don't finish some
Muslims go out and blow himself up for
the coochie ha
he will say that some isn't what
[Music]
he would say now you as a Christian
which Old Testament yes your need
exactly told it so mine exactly do you
prove my that's why I the way we were to
let me finish yes what's that the older
Bible the way we were told that if not
it's not chronological means things are
not in order
why it was as many reasons you want me
to get into I don't know I said I'm not
training yes because the chute you don't
need to be trained the point is the
commentary which we believe is chosen
took my sense a God appeared to where
the in the area who was Abraham was
sitting there with a promise certainly
he of the day and then if you continue
and they commenced relate on explains
the why did God sent three angels
because Abraham in the heat of the day
wanted so bad if you have visitors a
god-sent of angels making field oh right
that's what the commentators later under
view I think you see angels came that's
what then only later on to say I've
gotta patreon where exactly okay so we
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I got my knee okay most powerful no
answer is going to mind everything is
good a man
[Applause]